[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hello.
I'm Dan Galpin for
The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
In the rare case that a user's
Google account falls prey
to an attacker, the attacker can
also gain and maintain access
to your app via Google Sign In.
That's where Cross Account
Protection comes in.
It's a simple protocol
that enables two apps
to send and receive
security notifications
about a common user such
as account hijacked,
account disabled, and more.
To get started receiving
security events,
take a look at the post linked
in the description below.
Fuzzing is an automated method
for detecting bugs in software
that works by feeding unexpected
inputs to a target program.
In order for fuzzing
to be truly effective,
it must be continuous,
done at scale,
and integrated into
the development
process of a software project.
To provide these
features for Chrome,
we wrote ClusterFuzz, a
fuzzing infrastructure
running on over 25,000 cores.
Today, we're announcing
that ClusterFuzz is now
open sourced and available
for anyone to use.
Dopamine is our framework
for flexible reinforcement
learning.
Dopamine 2.0 is now available
and includes support
for discrete domain
gym environments.
Default configurations
are included
for two classic
control environments
that can be used to train a
Dopamine agent in minutes.
A link to the GitHub
repo is on the post.
The BigQuery sandbox
is now available.
It's a credit-card-free
path to enable you
to experiment with most
BigQuery features at no cost.
It provides you with
up to one terabyte
per month of query capacity
and 10 gigabytes of storage.
Links to get started
are on the post.
And if you want a cool
BigQuery dataset to play with,
check out these six
new cryptocurrency data
sets in BigQuery
public data sets.
Stackdriver Profiler lets you
understand the performance
impact of your code down
to each function call
and without sacrificing speed.
We've added new language and
platform support for Profiler,
along with weighted filtering
and other new filters.
All the details are on the post.
App Engine flexible
environment now
supports the WebSocket
protocol in beta,
which is the first time that
App Engine supports a streaming
protocol.
WebSockets are great for use
cases such as real-time event
updates, notifications,
chat applications, feeds,
collaborative editing tools,
and multiplayer games.
Links to the documentation
are on the post.
Chrome 73 Beta is now available
and includes constructive style
sheets, a new regular expression
function, and passive mouse
events.
All the details with
code are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Galpin for
Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
I'm Dan Galpin
[ROLLS TONGUE] Show.
[LAUGHS]
WOMAN: You've come a
long way since then.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]